there was I I want to say I saw an old
interview clip it might have been when
you were on flagrant where you had
pretty much I could be you know you're
right yeah I shut the door on it you
pretty much shut the door hard on like
what changed which is weird because
maybe a year before that I remember I
went on academics's podcast and he asked
if I would ever do a threesome with
another dude and my girl and I basically
like left the door open for it and was
just kind of like you know yeah I would
be open to it like I would be interested
in it I didn't say that I was gonna do
it but I said I'd be open to the idea
and I remember even at that time just me
suggesting that I would maybe be down
for it was so viral and such a big thing
and academics freaked out and could not
believe that I was acknowledging it and
even on Vlad there was a clip I saw like
because I I talked on interviews so much
that I forget what I say and but I'm
glad I said the same thing I said like
I would consider it you know and so yeah
like the clipping went viral though was
me saying that I definitely wouldn't do
it which is pretty funny but uh yeah I
mean what changed is basically just me
getting a little bit more open-minded as
time went by and like you know me and
her talked about like swinging off
camera and like hooking up with like a
different couple together or something
like that take a Friday night go out on
the town get a hotel room something like
that maybe but then we were like well if
we're ever gonna do that like we
probably should film it and if we're
gonna we should make some money yeah you
should probably like make your first
scene with another guy like a big
blowout thing pause
The Swinging world is crazy my cousin
and his ex-wife were swingers when I was
growing up okay and I'd be at his house
and the [__] would just be going down
bruh I'd be like 14 15 with all my
homies from school and we'd be watching
his wife [__] chop down on another
chick you'd be watching it oh yeah 14.
he literally my cousin literally would
be like hey you guys go outside and just
I'll leave the door I'll leave the
window cracked wow shout out to James
James I feel like you have a duty if
you're living that lifestyle to not have
uh 14 year olds around well it was yeah
yeah my cousin James was like I think he
was like 21 at the time so it was we
were we were like more friends than like
he was like my OG but they were they
were they'd go to these like uh Retreats
and they would go to these Resorts and
like yeah it's like a thing bro like I
mean Kazumi sent me a link to a book
about polyamorous relationships the
because I've never read about it or
research that or even really thought
about it because me and my girl are not
Polly in that sense like we just do porn
with other people do it for Content yeah
and even like you know we haven't hooked
up with another girl off camera in
probably like three four years at this
point so it's definitely like not
something I'm super familiar with we've
just been doing it for Content but you
know even like my girl yesterday like we
were on the Jason Lee podcast and she
just kind of said like yeah you know if
you were on a trip and you ended up
[__] some girl as long as you told me
like or or as long as you were safe
about it I don't think I would really
care that much I'm like wow like you're
you're Progressive your mind is changing
a bit because I remember when me and her
first got in the relationship she made
it very clear like you're on tour you're
on like if you're on the road you'll
[__] around yeah she was like I'm not
really [__] with that anymore like I
could get away with it for the first
year or two of our relationship but then
at some point she's like I'm not [__]
with that I'm Gonna Leave You if you
just [__] somebody cheating right yeah
like it's actual cheating you know but
like apparently she's kind of softened
up on that a bit although I don't really
trust these hoes enough to even do that
I don't want to be in a hotel room alone
with a girl yeah you know you'd be on
[__] Reddit with your ass out I don't
trust these [__] at all not even that
they're just gonna lie they're gonna say
that I did something you know oh yeah
especially with you bro yeah exactly
yeah yeah yeah no I like doing content
with her because then I have a guardian
who's actually like observing it and
nobody's able to ever to ever and that's
why even if I was gonna shoot porn just
me and another girl I would definitely
have like a real filmer so at least I
could have you have a witness yeah